[Music]
Stephen King is an American Author known
for horror suspense and fantasy novels
du the king of horror his books have
sold over 350 million copies worldwide
many of his Works have been adapted into
film series and Comics his debut was a
horror flick called Carri in 1974 which
was followed by notable movies like
salam's lot The Shining the Stan and the
dead zone there were many other
adaptations of his Works later on like
the famous it and it chapter 2 and also
the remakes dream catcher as well the
mist and so on so here in this video we
will showcase nine of the biggest
monsters from movies that are linked to
his Works let's get to
it number nine the Crimson creature seen
in the 2017 movie The Dark Tower this is
a min monster antagonist that was
summoned and created by the man in Black
who seeks to destroy a Dark Tower to
bring forth chaos into the universe when
the main character Jake travels through
a portal to a post-apocalyptic world
called the midor he must confront the
looming danger with the help of a
gunslinger it is here that he encounters
the Crimson creature which is a
quadrupedal monster and has a very long
tail it is very agile and has a mouth
full of sharp teeth although not the
overarching enemy it does threaten to
kill both Jake and the gun Slinger and
was only put down after sheer hardship
and a chance of
luck number eight Mr Gray in Stephen
King's dream catcher Mr Gray the alien
commander of the virus species aims to
infect the world with a parasitoid alien
macro virus known as riplay these aliens
resemble deformed serpent-like beings
and can reproduce asexually and possess
telepathic abilities the adult aliens
and their offsprings nicknamed the
weasels have carnivorous instincts while
their telepathic powers allow them to
appear as gray aliens you know the
typical gray aliens that are seen in
Roswell New Mexico or movies associated
with it anyway Mr Gray is huge around 10
ft tall and has a very long tail with
sharp endings and appears to be able to
communicate and mind control people in a
way for his own selfish desires while
exuding a selfless benevolence at the
same time number seven the giant mbat
this is a strange mutated monster from
the 1990 movie called the graveyard
shift in the movie young Drifter called
Hall was employed at a rundown textile
mill and was enlisted by a harsh foran
called Warwick for a major cleaning tars
so the Mills basement abandoned for
decades houses a colossal rat
infestation that has given rise to A
peculiar ecosystem this rat Empire
features various evolved creatures
including large armored rats albino
weasel likee climbers and borrowers and
also batlik rats that have grown to be
the size bigger than a cow with wings
that can stretch 15 ft wide
number six Pennywise in spider form the
creature called it or Pennywise an
extra-dimensional entity has its Origins
from a dimension called the Dead Lights
it is seen in the movie it and its
sequel chapter 2 and the remakes it can
change forms and take on a variety of
shapes and sizes aside from its normal
clown form this transformative ability
is not only confined by special
limitations allowing it to manifest in
multiple locations simultaneously in
diverse forms during the transition
between shapes its body can transform
into an orange shapeless substance
notably it altering its form seems to
consume energy as evidence by its
reversion to a giant spider-like form
when injured this emphasizes that a
spider form is a representation closest
to the human comprehension of its true
nature and it is pretty
huge number five the Tentacles from
planet eggs so this is a grotesque slimy
and enigmatic Creature from the movie
called The Mist its name is given
sarcastically by the the characters of
the movie so besides it very long squid
like tentacle appearance the monster is
also equipped with claws or sharp spikes
along the sides of its tentacles and
also a slit-like mouth near the tip they
can emit High shrieking sounds and can
retract their mouths and Claws into
their flesh and display a coloration
blending gray and pink when a severe
tentacle meets as demise it rapidly
decomposes into a sizzling black liquid
although it is pretty huge there its
full body is never really seen and is
still a
mystery number four He Who Walks Behind
The Rose this creature here is a demonic
Spirit masquerading as a perverted
fertility deity corrupting the children
of a remote town called Gatlin into a
murderous cult killing all adults in the
movie The Children of the Corn and its
sequels referred to as He Who Walks
Behind The Rose this malevolent force is
never really visually depicted in the
story but exerts a pervasive influence
the origins and a true nature of this
entity is shrouded in in mystery and it
is characterized as an evil force rather
than a tangible being in the Cinematic
adaptations he has the ability to
possess his followers and bestow demonic
Powers upon them when taking physical
form he assumes a perplexing amorphous
appearance featuring claws corn husk and
an overall bewildering body
design number three the Arachne Lobster
this arach Lobster is a formidable
predator in the movie called The M maybe
the biggest predator there it is a
two-story talk creature with a very
fleshy skin which is gray in color it
features a slouch torso supported by six
arthropod-like legs it also has large
pincer tipped arms which resembles uh
some kind of a crap and a mantis the
head is defined by an enormous vertebrae
style mouth with needle-like teeth while
its coloration remains indistinct always
appearing as a silhouette on screen the
menacing creature dispatches its victims
by either cutting them in half with his
claws or by fighting off their heads
with his mouth number two the long boy
the sole entry from the TV series called
Lizzy story it is based on Stephen
King's world as well long boy is a
monster that lives in a magical
Dimension called the booya Moon it
wanders around only at night and is the
source of a beastly State called the bad
gunky long boy haunts people it sees for
their entire lives making them unable to
look at mirrors and other reflective
surfaces in the series it appears not as
a wormlike serpent from from the books
but as an amalgamation of hundreds of
human corpses that move and wriggle to
snatch and devour other people into the
Abominable
form and number one the Behemoth the
biggest here in this list also comes
from the movie The Mist the Behemoth
also known as The impossibly Tall
creature is a colossal six-legged entity
encountered by the skps at the end of
the movie standing over 240 ft tall with
six double-jointed legs and many
appendages and tentacles it surpasses
any Earthly creature in size by
magnitudes despite its immense stature
it doesn't seem to harm anyone and
appears to be non-hostile possibly
because it is too large to even notice
anything beneath it maybe its diet or
its place in the food chain is way above
ours and doesn't really recognize us as
spray items its sheer size however does
pose a great danger and instills an
incomprehensible Terror and fear in
people that see it which suggests it
somehow is a Herald of an ominous re
reality anyway those are the nine
biggest monsters from Stephen King's
movies Stephen King though is more
famous for his horror monsters than
giant creatures movies like The Shining
The Dead Zone and Kujo don't have big
monsters at all but they still do hit
the same spot with their themes and
plotline so anyway if you like this
video then check this other one as well
and if you're more interested in other
movie monsters and creatures then check
out our Channel we might just have
things you haven't seen before so like
subscribe and will see you on the next
video till the next one take care
fam